those of you who don't know who
am I that's homophobia
comedians are a famously outspoken Bunch
but in a year that seen controversial
jokes by big hitters like Dave Chappelle
and Jimmy Carr lead to a torrent of
vitriol and rage how are comedians at
The Fringe coping with standing up to
cancel culture
these days Oma jalili is being schooled
by his kids what we have to do is
comedians in our 50s just make little
adjustments things that we think are
tremendously funny we'll run it by our
kids and the kids say I know why your
generation thinks that's funny but we
don't
Reginald D Hunter has spent 20 plus
years perfecting the art of delivering
controversial material people are
feeling powerless but due to economics
and the jobs and the politics of the
time and so the few things that they
have any power over they're really
they're really doubling up on it and so
they have power over their opinions
support Simon brodkin the controversial
comedian who handed Theresa May a fake
p45 when it comes to pushing boundaries
where does he draw the line but whenever
I write a joke
I'm always thinking to myself
can I justify that joke and is that a
joke that I'm happy to say and proud to
say in front of everyone and do I know
who I'm directing that joke at and once
I feel comfortable in that I'm cool I
will defend that
of course what people find funny changes
over time
back in the 80s the term woke hadn't
even been invented yet some of the same
Notions lay at the heart of alternative
comedy with politically aware comedians
leading the charge against racist and
sexist humor so it's the very idea that
modern comedians are having their free
speech stifled actually a bit flawed
with his spoof show about being no
platformed believes debates around Free
Speech shouldn't be dismissed I think
when there's an intention of hate behind
it which there are with some people that
hate is an energy and it can Ripple out
and I think it can have real world
knock-on effects in an uptick of
violence and hatred and intolerance
towards marginalized people and
communities
comedians at the
foot it always has and always will be
about balancing on the edge of what's
appropriate Katie Spencer Sky News in
Edinburgh